tell me Jackson yeah I know that's a
problem
okay all right thank you very much
my name is only krump and I'll be
channeling during planning East tonight
but before we start meeting proper I
would just like to thank previous
chairmen Simon Jackson and Johnny
Kendall who I've sat and watched over
the years and learned a lot from them so
if you are not impressed my performance
tonight and the job you know who to by
so and case the Kenda was just over
there also be helpful if members could
limit themselves to planning related
questions and statements is what's in
Sherman they ask the questions to
decrypt the person in other words don't
ask the parish council with technical
questions that more suited to the case
officer but before I introduce the top
table please could everyone insure their
mobile phones or devices are turned off
or put on silent because there's nothing
worse for a speaker to be in full flow
when they're into and then they're
interrupted by the theme tune to The
Great Escape and now we'll start with
introductions and we'll start on my
right and banks from committee services
Ross chambers legal services Kevin Tate
I'm team leader plumbers east in my role
was an impartial advisor to the
committee I can clarify any planning
issues that arise doing so unbound by
the code of Professional Conduct of the
Royal Town Planning Institute planning
committee members are not bound by the
case offices recommendation or by oral
advice Thank You Eddie wrench senior
planning officer James Hodgkins planner
thank you very much almost sounds like
University Challenge isn't it I think
I'll probably be reading the B now if I
was my specialty subject and first item
on the agenda chairman we have apologies
from councillor Perry for whom
councillor Cargill is substituting where
our apologies from counselor or Donnell
for whom councillor Williams is
substituting
and we have apologies from cancellous
and thank you thank you
catch the car go on cancel Williams sir
give me all the time to help us out and
move on to item 2 disclosure of interest
have we any on tonight's no I've just
one item 82 sorry I should say chair I
oughta mates in my ward so I'll step
down from the committee for that one
that's okay thank you
caster Williams will you be any
disclosure of interest or no right
number three minutes of meetings held on
11 April and the second of May am i I'll
pay the art and so on those people
remembers happy right we just need to
have a slight change on the agenda if
you'll bear with us on this one
not to bring forward item number 6 which
is the application for cottage farm
Bambi roegadyn Warwick and I will ask
Eddie wrench to give us the reasons why
so if you'll be happy to take that one
forward Thank You chair following our
negotiations with the local ward member
and officers the applicant
agreed to an amended description of
development reducing the number of
temporary years from three to two and
with this the war local ward member
removed their objection so the officers
are asking members to vote on whether it
can be delegated to officers for
approval now thank you
and catch the bromance a comeback all
those in favor here in this chair Thank
You committee resolves to turn the gate
backs application 18 / 0 0 1 5 8 4 all
right thank you very much we'll move to
the next item on the agenda which is
application number 18 / 0 0 3 all right
ful plan inside lane Fannie Compton and
this is for the erection of the detached
dwelling house encourage the percent of
officer is a t range I'll pass over to
Eddie Thank You chair the application
site lies on the eastern edge of Finney
Compton as denoted here by the black dot
public right-of-way SM 141 runs through
the application site along the access
road as denoted here by the dashed green
line the application site is adjacent to
the neighboring dwelling at the end of
that road as shown at the end of the
road here the application site is within
the ironstone here special landscape
area this planet shows the built-up area
boundary for Fenny compton with the
application site at the end of mill mill
lane as shown here by the red dot this
is the submitted site layout I'm showing
the dwelling proposed to be on the
western side of the boundary with access
from the east of Mill Lane these are the
proposed elevations for the for the
dwelling which would have an integrated
tube acreage this plan shows the
proposed floor plans showing the three
bedrooms and home office that would be
utilizing the first floor
now onto some of the site pictures this
is a view from the proposed access of
the site looking back towards the
neighboring property which is stud land
mill note that the application site is
currently an agricultural field this
photo shows is from Mill Lane looking
along the public right-of-way with the
proposed site on the right-hand side and
the neighboring dwelling in the
background the red line denotes a rough
boundary along the edge line and finally
this is another view from Mill Lane
looking eastwards showing the
neighboring properties access and the
proposed access to the application which
is denoted by chairman updates include
another letter of support from the
neighboring property and an updated
recommendation to allow for the expiry
of the relevant consultation and
advertisements which are due to expire
on the 21st of next month thank you
thank you ready we'll move on to our
first speaker will she catch the John
Doe from when you come to the parish
council now if you come to the come to
the front place you have
that's right thank you you have about
three hello is it working yet Brent
we've got three minutes councillor
Dutton would you like a warning with 30
seconds to go
yes thank you so the Squires have lived
in the village for a couple of
generations have been active members of
the community members of local
organisations in organizing mostly local
events another reason that as I
understand it they're having to move out
the existing property which they've
occupied for a long time is because the
landlords are evicting them and there is
a general feeling in the community that
we want these people to stay and
maintain an active role in the community
and therefore we are in support of their
application to remain the extent of
super thank you very much that was nice
and 6/16 cancer conquer thank you one of
the items have been raised as a lack of
application for local needs housing
within the within the community the
parish or need there was a survey so
there's no identified local need that's
wrong getting that all the or is there
within the community generally cancer
brain cancer doesn't good evening I
understand you have a neighbourhood plan
in the process of developing a
neighbourhood
why would this site be in that
neighborhood plans for development side
versus outside the village boundary I
don't know at this stage thank you any
other questions I've got two first
question is
councillor Dalton could you explain what
you mean in the committee papers you
support subject to condition that the
property should not be useful
agricultural habitation stroke use yes
so we're happy for the resins to be used
as the residence but we didn't want to
be used for no I stopped playing yep and
my other question is that obviously the
post council supported it was that
unanimous support yes okay thank you any
any further questions
tents the bonds would I be correct in
saying you're only supporting it because
there is a need yes right thank you very
much I think we've let you off lightly
tonight sir thank you very much put your
back is back shortly
all right so our next speaker is Karl
Middleditch I believe mr. Middleditch
and I mr. Squires is with you for to
answer questions is that right super
thank you I'm sure you know the forum
but three minutes and if you want a
warning we're happy to give you about 30
seconds
mr. chairman his college marketing
consultant speaking on behalf of mr. mr.
Squier who were present form of the
Grange infinity compton based upon a
farm tenancy business penalty from
Christchurch apologize for they took
over the farm from mrs. parents in their
own 450 acres the parents still
unfortunately Christchurch colleagues
wish to develop the farm and farm
buildings and in 2017
mr. mr. Squire to vacate their farming
businesses based upon hands from a few
days old
taking them to around 20 to 22 months
the number of capital at the end of 2017
be 237 promises very age plus 30 to 35
Angus cross Chapel for finishing for the
lead role in addition they have 80 to 90
breeding ewes producing some 140 to 160
lambs enemy they've already made
arrangements for their livestock to be
found in the existing buildings
elsewhere
which is the seconds and I respectfully
ask for your support
thank you very much any questions
castor cargo just one please it is to do
with the road that the properties the
proposed properties on is that a main
road or is it just a bridge well it's a
main trend but it's not a public highway
okay
and it serves about eight or nine of the
dwelling is that a private road it's a
private road thank you thank you I've
got one I've got spring and then I lost
my last I'm just interested in far away
the livestock is its back on range from
where I was a tenant than the new tenant
is an arable farm and he's came to me to
carry on doing the livestock portion off
so it's two fields away we'd be facing
it this two fields across if you wanted
to look up there on the plan it's just
at the bottom the corner where the road
right at the bottom disappears off the
buildings they've just approximately
there okay thank you just got another
point unless the materials haven't been
identified yet is that correct that's
correct so we intend to use the facing
brick and clay plain tile but we will
agree those sympathetic to the
sympathetic the house next door is in
facing with Chancellor Barnes my right
in saying that the building that's the
not the track that the house is on if
you drop to the bottom of the the screen
there's a road you can see marking off
which leads off the pathway right that's
the Slade and just as at the bottom as
that road disappears that's where the
fight existing farm buildings are yeah
my question again relates to the support
from the parish council where they've
requested a condition that a property
should not be used for any agricultural
habitation etc what are what are your
views on that well although mr. and as
far as the farmers they do not intend to
use it in association with buildings to
be constructed there's no intention of
building putting further buildings on
the paddock and thank you
right any nothing that's it for
questions all right thank you Jim
we now move on to our wooden on that
catch the Williams 5min situation well
we'll give you that thirty seconds
warning
good evening committee this unfortunate
this even coming to committee for
determination if you look at that
drawing off any Compton I'll be very
pleased to know where this spare land
where a house could be built there is no
more available land within the building
to set up a fairly hold apart from two
developments one which is a hundred
hours is another one is 60 houses the
applicant wanted to build a small house
that enabled him to carry on his life
the family's work on the farm
he can't relocate why should you read
arcade the family of what this farm
since covers a little boy the essence of
this application is how do we comply
with all the restrictions that are
available to somebody and the only land
is land his father morons and we thought
was best if he put the house next to the
string of houses that were all there so
it's just like one more house in a very
quiet road itself a flamboyant house
sort of massive stainless steel and
smoked glass windows he said traditional
house which is it expect to see in the
site the support for the African is
quite extraordinary already I think if I
can just now I've got a letter of
support from mr. Crofton he lived in LA
he was going to come tonight but
unfortunately a little missing about
this application they were told
date was changed to middle of July but
he does made a couple of expressions I
think you should just put the holding in
context as previously stated is their
intention to raise cattle and sheep on
land which the family evolved for many
years and land saved to go to rent from
the new tenant as I'm sure you're aware
and have taken into consideration just
for practical purposes you know to farm
the land with livestock the farmer has
to live in close proximity the livestock
in case of emergencies
having seen the plans for dwelling which
is not an over large she was borne in
mind that no one objection has been
raised in the village very important not
one objection is said now we want to
protect the built up area the
application is the only attraction
spoken shows through high regard
villagers have for mr. Squier surely
people living and working verge of
objections versions should not be
refused
one of the basic formulas we all have to
consider was what material harm is
caused by this building and I can't
think of any harm that is caused by this
building it seems to be so integrated
into a string of houses there's no
photographs of the other houses they
look similar parents daughters breed
from forest the report but he doesn't
address any reasons for repose objection
apart from its outside the building line
well yes the building line that mythical
drawing has done the back office but any
reference to local considerations but
she asked to consider the identified
local need and housing needs survey
completed in 2008 what relevance is one
completed ten years ago with 2018 we're
living now
there was as we heard before we're in
the process of dropping a neighborhood
plan and when the neighbour plan has
carried out a housing needs survey the
applicants were at that time expecting
to stay in the house they've lived in
all their life
but questions college who owns the land
now want to develop the land why is it
alive for a college to convert farmhouse
to private housing not for somebody to
carry on living it that's another matter
but I think the paragraph on page 25 is
quite ruined if we consider the salary
impacts high rates matters well yes that
can just be negotiated roar Rodgers says
that in effect sustainable energy this
house has got sustainable energy more
than any of the other houses bought long
sided 30 seconds okay I just feel you
should put this prep generation won't we
the consequences of not supporting this
application consequence were a family
that lived in penny Compton and a farmer
who's that son-in-law of the original
landowner would have to relocate he may
not relocate he could convert the
paddock to farmland and have buildings
and farm buildings which report couldn't
stop this is a much better application
to consider what's going to be achieved
consider yourself there has not been any
building within the built-up area for
some considerable time councillor bonds
there is no suitable land within that
area to build a new house question in
two parts find devil's advocate here so
playing devil's advocate if this
say you're actually on committee and
this came to you from another Ward and
we've got the policy of the built-up
area boundary would would you be
sporting that with the same parameters
as this application have to be yes of
course why would or not thank you very
much just just asking the question right
thank you catch the rhythms you turn the
microphone off please right we move on
to points of clarification before a Dean
can catch the Barnes in case the brain
because you do know special lands Gabe
area yes do you want to know which one I
understand he'll special landscape areas
that's the brain to demonstrate a local
need if it advence trait there was a
local need would it override the
boundary yes because one of the
exceptions in CS 15 is for a local needs
dwellings outside the built very
boundary so yeah it's just a case of the
evident can I just spawned not on what
what evidence what more episode council
right now no corner operator in terms of
the course strategy it's either I think
which which has been mentioned before a
local housing needs survey which is
often done for a parish plan generally
and up to date one or the neighborhood
development plan coming forward with
details of local needs sites is
generally the sort of evidence that we
look
all right my only point clarification
area our current is that what this crate
is precedent I know we look at cases on
an individual basis but by going to this
for this president in terms of local
needs schemes they are all based on very
individual circumstances the evidence
for that particular village and that you
know that particular families
circumstances as well so I wouldn't say
it's necessarily a precedent for the
type of evidence but you know it's
generally not as robust as what we would
normally look for in other villages I
would say the only point you could draw
from it thank you the cargo just to
comment well please Eddie if this
committees minded to grand plan for
Mission for this and would a condition
be put on this to effectively become a
local needs property in local news Bobby
if members were minded to approve the
scheme then we would advise basically
having a section 106 agreement to secure
that properties a local needs dwelling
in perpetuity yeah that's correct
chairman if members supported this
application we would suggest that
section 106 agreement is entered into
and this would ensure that going forward
every time the property is sold it needs
to be sold to somebody with a local
connection to the village that's what we
do with other local needs schemes within
the district so that's what we'd seek to
ensure here thank you
on to the debates I'm just a quick one
on this one
is there anything we would also consider
on PD rights as well for this I think if
we were looking to approve because of
the special landscape area location edge
of village location and the general
sensitivity from the public
rights-of-way in the locality then we
would look to remove certain PD rights
for boundary treatments or new buildings
and extensions I think as well you know
I think I'll just add on tonight as well
would you have some draft conditions
that if we want you to agree or this
that you would have available for this
one I have got some rough conditions
with us thank you
catch the bones if we were to approve
because we asked it's only an outline
plan or an idea could be asked that it
came back for you know when it when it's
been everything agreed or are we all
happy that the officer could do that you
understand what I'm saying yeah it's a
full application isn't it
chalices are full application so you
have the details in front of you to
consider tonight landscaping we haven't
got the boundary that sort of thing
which as far as I can see isn't on there
I'm just saying as it out of the village
boundary we wanted you to look at there
it isn't Kong's I think and you did say
you've got some conditions potentially
yeah I don't know if you want me to go
through the sort of conditions it might
cover yeah the standard conditions I
think we'd be looking for in this case
would be obviously three years in
accordance with the plans particularly
this location we would look for sample
of the materials be using the building
details of the foul and surface water
drainage on the site environmental
health also ask for a contaminated land
condition we would look for hard and
soft landscaping so details of all the
boundary treatments and any additional
planting there there's also quite a
significant tree to the front boundary
so we'd ask for some tree protection for
that then it would be the standard
wheelie bins water births and then
picking up on the other point it would
be the removal of the certain IDI rights
which I've discussed sorry did we
mention about the livestock goes to the
post canceled service condition for that
story is that or would that be generally
they need permission because it would be
a c3 use so anything that would bring
livestock or agricultural buildings on
or near to the site would require
further permissions yes my
interpretation is that the Parish
Council
concerned that the the intention would
be to create a farm a farmyard farmhouse
and farmyard that is my reading of their
objection and the the the concern is
about the farmyard part so the
associated agricultural buildings barns
as you'll see from the site area we
actually have a very limited site over
here would be potentially possible to to
put some very small buildings on here
livestock buildings but clearly the site
that you have in front of you is is set
out and designed to as a residential
site so there doesn't appear to be any
intention to include or move towards
including farm buildings that are later
date yeah
I'm quite happy that we've got the the
formal position that they would have to
reapply and also with other the
assurance from the applicant that that
wasn't going to be the case anyway so I
think we I think we need to have a
condition as long as you agree with that
and I think we could move on to the
debate if we've got no further questions
okay so Brian chairman I think the
officers were corrected in their
appraisal of this application and for
the refusal but listening to the
evidence without before us I think we
after a portion the particular weight on
these particular things and assess
material arm as well and I think that's
been demonstrated by the speakers
tonight it I was full of full support
from the parish council from the ward
member and apparently from the neighbors
as well so I think the harm is minimal
the apportion weight we can put the
weight towards the application and I for
one would support the application of
supply tool thank you caster bars
yes I think we're here committee because
there is a need a local need obviously
it's against policy cuz it's out of the
village boundary but we had one last
week out of the village boundary I think
they had one at Wells borne some months
ago in the middle of a field so I think
we're bringing a special situation we're
at committee it's a decision we have got
as the last speaker said a lot of
support so uncooperative proposed if the
conditions for landscape is something -
and not if it's a second did you say
brain this professor guess the cargo
Thank You Jimmy
well I think it's a very modest design
in fitting within the area and obviously
with some conditions on the actual
materials I think it'd be a good
addition to the property to the the area
I it is again there's no identified
housing needs survey done formally but
this is as close as you're ever gonna
get to a local local needs scheme and I
just can't see any reason we shouldn't
go along with that so I support it it's
supporting rural economy it's on a small
country lane there's no or low impact as
is stated in the report by the officer
chairman I'm fully in support of this
right I'll just add my two panelist
awesome here yeah I'm say this it's good
that it's come to committee in effect
because we've actually got to the nub of
the issue we've we've dug down and found
there is the local support for it and
was proud to supporting and promoting
and sustaining a rural business which is
what we am to do in this Authority
certainly by questioning the parish
council the applicant and the agent and
also listening to cancer Williams for
five minutes we've certainly got to know
what was going on
and I think I agree with counts the
cargo this is for as in the true
definition of a local needs application
which is a shame misinformation to come
to committee to tease this information
out and perhaps there are learning
points for all concerned regarding this
and hopefully the parish council can
again take these points on board they
are support in an application like this
they can get their evidence as strong as
possible it snowed rusev is just some
advice hopefully so on I'm intended to
go along with case of brains proposed
also but if we're happy to I made a note
about retention of a tree removal of PD
art and a 106 agreement which I think we
have to take into consideration it's
this I think is worthy of retention to
keep some of the character so yeah we
look for some protection just for that
during construction and section 106
unhappy about Russ we saw the gate that
was going to be the entrance that's
correct yes so the age in everything
worse day yes basically the protective
fencing that we proposed would just be
to protect it from you know during
construction really P yeah well I
suggest chair is that the the precise
wording of conditions is delegated to
officers in consultation with yourself
and that the resolution to grant is also
subject to a section 106 agreement to
secure the local needs house in
perpetuity
if you're happy with that calibrate
nicely we go to the vote all those in
favor no miss chairman right this
committee resolves to grant funding
application reference 1800 threw away a
few well and with the conditions
mentioned just part of catch the brain
and delegation to officers regarding
section 106 thank you
all right just yes eventually when we
move on to our next item on the agenda
which is 18 / 0 0 1 7 4 / o UT hang farm
the tamal farmer Bunbury at lawn
permission for two houses and the case
officer
it's James Hodgkins Thank You chair
so as denoted by the black dots the
application site is located to the east
of the village of Fanny Compton the
application seeks outline permission for
two dwellings with all matters reserved
for future consideration here you can
see the site to consist of two
triangular part plots they sit to the
north of the Aqsa Canal down here there
are a couple of Berman public footpaths
in the vicinity but not through the site
and the host dwelling home farm located
in the middle section here the site is
also located within the ironstone Hill
special landscape area so if we just
move here this is just an aerial
photography of the site so I said that
the canal and then the is just down here
if you can see just off my screen the
two stars just mark the rough plots so
plot one and plot two everywhere the
proposed drawings ought to go so that is
the the location plan submitted
alongside the application which also
shows the access I would point out that
the abscess details offer future
consideration but this is this is the
fun being considered by highways I've
submitted
that's just the existing just just
highlighting again plot one down here
and plot see over to the right just got
a few photographs to cycle through and
so this is the view to the plot one from
the access point this is the neighboring
property and the host property it's just
off screen here but there's another
photo that should show that and this is
the view again from the abscess looking
into plot two no more difficult to get a
photo of this one but just looking into
the plot - they're just off to the right
of the of the home founders to the south
and then this is adjacent to where plot
one will go so if we just say I'm stood
at the very corner of the sites looking
into the situation of plot one so
looking back and this is the current
road positioning so this is home farm
located within the middle and the
neighbor and the area the neighboring
property here so roughly speaking what
want to sit somewhere in this vicinity
as we said in terms of heights
sorry scale etc I'd be reserved for
future consideration but it generally
speaking in that location there and
German the recommendation is to refuse
planning permission for the reasons
outlined within the committee report
there are no further updates thank you
thank you James
back on to our first speaker again and
it's counselor dozen yeah I'm not gonna
need a three minute so we may have been
caught out slightly my understanding of
process I think what we want to point
way to get across on this one was we
didn't have any particular objection to
it
her understanding based on the
application was that it was a brownfield
site and therefore to the point of order
to make was that we didn't have any
objection on the grounds that it was a
brownfield site if you've been a
greenfield site we don't make sense you
know if I've misunderstood the process
of how to get that across then I'm happy
to take thank you any questions here's
the cargo just tease up on out a little
bit and you say you're you wouldn't
object if you're not projecting if it's
a brownfield strike both agreeing feels
that you would object yes right if it
were a greenfield site what would your B
objections be based upon
okay open this in the it would it be
anything other than just simply the fact
is outside the belt a very boundary
openness that comes your side I'm just
well we didn't go into that level of
debate around this particular site so I
could give you an opinion would
necessary based on counsel might say no
no so perfectly alright thank you mr.
bones did you indicate or we just sort
of checking it that was my understanding
of the process to make a comment you
have to either support or object was my
understanding with the process if that's
not right then please tell them no thank
you very much showcase the Dom thank you
for taking the time and trouble to come
oh yeah we could do enough assistive
explain it yeah I think that's a good
point caster Coco Coco Coco is shall we
explain the process to so generally
speaking parish councils get three ops
but it could either choose not to
comment until they could make an
objection they can make a support or
they can make a no representation if in
making an objection or a support that
doesn't agree with the officers
recommendation then it's a trigger for
planning committee right so I don't have
long debate about this but if we wanted
to make a comment we would need to
either support or object no you could
make a representation with a comment
alongside so no representation but with
an additional comment so neither support
nor object would have to be made clear
that you're not supporting objecting and
leaving it to officers delegated
authority it's the objection or support
that I could differ from the officer
they could therefore lead to committee
trader and I'm go sometimes I think well
are quite supportive regarding the
process as well so whether the
might consider that speaking to them
about the process as well for for some
advice as well which which might help as
well thank you right move on to our next
speaker was mr. John Beckett who's the
applicant I thought the parish council
was in support of my application and it
sounded from that from what I could hear
that they aren't talk about that and
join the braids debate late but they Bob
see is come to committee because I've
supported it so we're working on the
process that they have supported and
that's why it's come to committee and
we've questioned the counts the further
to get a bit more clarification so I
think we'll just leave it at that and
then you'll have your three mates - yeah
put your case forward so we want a
reminder warning it within 30 seconds
yep thank you so you've got three
minutes
Thank You council can support me or no I
found conferred that this year has been
delayed twice already which was agreed
to give proper consideration to the
application and it seems to me that a
justification for turning it down is
hinging on the open countryside
consideration and I would like to bring
to the people's notice that whilst it is
situated in open countryside as we all
would understand these two little bits
of ground are marooned in positions
whereas they have no further use to
agriculture the soil itself is heavy
clay and all previous owners of this
site of gone bankrupt
because of this the only one side of the
two sides going up the road there are
two houses one of which was a large
public house in the recent past and on
the south side there is in existence a
concrete milking parlor no longer used a
Brickyard site with massive brick kiln
being restored spoil reeks loading
machinery water store behind the two
sites of course there is our own house
you could call it the find their own
house a concrete garage and 18 concrete
barns last use 20 years ago because the
site is an economic in an agricultural
sense the remaining ground in the
remaining ground there are all sorts of
old foundations and floor slabs of two
cottages numerous concrete basis of
previous buildings and in the particular
pieces of ground we are discussing is
similar kind of concrete obstructions
which would smash any farm implements on
the roadside the i-40 3/32 mr. Bishop we
have concrete canal bridge concrete
railway bridge railway maintenance yard
and the whole of this is literally
peppered with tree cover so that the
apparently is countryside but in close
examination
it can be easily shown that is not any
good for farming these two little
squares the main farming land is good
behind our house hopefully yeah yeah
thank you very much okay say there's be
some questions from yeah from members
any any questions against the kaga just
a question you mentioned a couple of the
the foundations of some continent
proximately do you happen to know how
all those cottages were the cottages
that you identified as in in plot one is
one that I actually demolished myself
when we built our new house so that is
20 years ago it was standing the all the
rest of the remains our previous to that
body before we came on the site and I
think a lot of the buildings were put
out of use when the canal was using a
lot of extra space for spoil heat which
is still there lava so and then of
course a lot of the concrete shed bases
which exist in the two squares were put
in by previous farmers of this site okay
thank you thank you mr. Beckett you're
free to go now thank you thank you and
they'll all go on to our ward number
okay so the Williams again
right okay so I was just making sure
you're comfortable sorry I didn't want
to rush this Thank You mr. chairman
could you just tell me what I've got 30
seconds left
to quote Mike spike I ought to tell you
a story if you look on page 33 summary
railroad in history gets a very bottom
line demolition of existing cottage at
some farm buildings and construction of
a new house and carriage that was
granted in the 2nd of June 1998 20 years
ago that was the first Planning
Committee I went to when there was a
desert planning committee in those days
we had no national planning policy
framework or anything like that and you
just grants things we didn't grant it
really if you liked it or not
I really felt this house so what I'm
just went was granted approval but now I
must clearly state we have before us an
outline planning permission only an
outline planning patient not a full
planning person which is another word
for sake we want to obtain permission in
principle to developed of this site
object to the site on sustainability
crowns its increasing the number of
houses from two to four it's quite an
increase in a small area which is
entirely rural the nearest shop is
fairly competent probably two and a half
miles away the a four to three is a very
busy road recently a child or killed
coming from the adjacent house not the
applicants house next door
crossing the road was hit by a school
bus or something but one thing is
imagine the next stage on if you agree
in principle to this development and
their families buy these houses how does
the child go to school does he walk or
do they go in car if they walk can you
imagine a five-year-old walking long
after school or two miles to school
the bother walking with the charter
school two miles in two miles back then
the end of day going to track them or if
they go in a car it does ten miles extra
day and sustainability grounds is that
barble it is really a located location
it's very isolated so I must stress it's
the sustainability of this site that I
can't support there's much talk about
that there's no need for that those
particular houses the reference to the
pit or the form of cloud workings yes
it's a very interesting archaeological
site which was never really developed by
the various authorities you looked at
they all said yes interesting me but who
will pay for it all and never happened
thinking about the facilities the
nearest pub is probably the closest
thing to it which is further on towards
for any comfort on the main road but if
you want to buy food in the shop that's
in Fanny Compton if you wanna go to
school that's in Fanny Compton the
doctors are in 20 continent all the
services of life support are probably to
more than two miles away and I just
think it on the last case I was asked or
questioned by you mr. chairman would I
support a similar application and I said
if the conditions were similar these
this condition is not similar this is a
development in the rural location
outside the built-up area of the village
miles from the built-up area not
adjacent to it and we have these
built-up areas to protect our heritage
and I just feel this is an abuse of our
heritage it's asking for an outline
planning permission no details of what's
involved and just say we want to agree
in principle to develop the property so
our objection to it on sustainability
clear we know no other details its
location I think it's inappropriate for
new housing to increase the number of
houses from two to four is ridiculous
and I just can't support the
supplication
I'll be happy to answer any questions
now I think you were very clear there
cancer wins thank you very much thank
you all right we'll move on to points of
clarification I mean it was all pretty
clear but James tonight actually get to
the debate who wants to start
we'll start with counts the bars for
change see that we can go along with the
officers recommendations and development
in the open countryside and fully
support what's been written
yes LeBron second now and the other
comments
we were happy without our longest I
think this is this one page 35 in
particular where CS 15 and said 16 the
various points that we could use to two
grand to build in he doesn't fulfill any
alert criteria and I must admit on
minded to support the officers
recommendation as well so should we go
to the vote on this one all right okay
so Brian all those in favor of kept
surveillance providers or to refuse oh
sorry I'm so used to you proposing
proposing to me counts of rains then
catch the Barnes's proposal seconded by
Councillor brain all those in favor
unanimous journals so this committee
resolves to refuse application 18 / 0 0
once and for UT
the second thank you all right move on
to agenda item number seven yeah
services application 17 / 0 3 2 right
now on ful and it's unit non ships and
business village tiles moon's lying
ship Salon star change the views from be
to use to do to Asia and James is
presenting the game Thank You chair so
yeah as denoted by the black dot again
the site here is located to the north of
ship stone within the ship Stern built a
barrier boundary and within the ship
Stern business village as helps the
compass highlighted the application is
for the change of use from b2 which is
general industry to a d2 at leisure use
and specifically a gymnasium so here you
can see that there's a public footpath
at the very bottom at the road here but
generally speaking oh no other site
constraints this just outlines of again
I'll just use the star just outline
where the unit nine actually is itself
just sits in between unit 210 and eight
at the center point here I've got a few
photographs just - oh sorry apologies
and so this is the current current site
and this is the proposed floor Palin of
the gym so that's the internal internal
arrangements so this is the car parking
arrangements as part of the plan the
redline only includes these four car
parking spaces however this has been
sought further from the applicant and he
was shown that these to be donated from
other business units this is a written
agreement in letter form from from the
units however there's nothing in place
to secure these in perpetuity this is
just some photos now I can cycle through
so that's the the unit that present
unit 9 is actually vacant the units
either side are occupied and again just
the view of the towards the car park and
this is the view back to Tom and Elaine
chair again the application is
recommended for refusal I was outlined
within the committee report there are no
updates are getting this one thank you
thank you I believe no speakers on this
and I know that cats the same didn't
object and easy but you see also so
we'll move on to points of clarification
yeah
sorry the parking I think it revolves
around up he meant you think I didn't
quite pick you I apologize parking
spaces were being agreed with others in
perpetuity did you use that word no
sorry so what I can so what effectively
happened so the redline sites includes
these four car parking spaces here
following comments from County highways
the applicant has gone out to his
neighboring units who have agreed that
the spaces can be used outside of their
business hours so weekends and and post
five o'clock and it's written in letter
format however they they are not agreed
in perpetuity as they cannot be secured
by condition because they're outside the
application site yes there's a letter
agreement but nothing solidified and
that's why it's come to committee and
then to just carry if I'm parking is
there then the option for them to park
on the road if they the spaces are
filled and what are the sort of
constraints and again of highways
objected on that particular part of it
yes so the road again the road here down
to Tolman's Lane so Thomas Lane is
public highway and this road here is
private there is options for cars to
park along this road but that is one of
highways objections for indiscriminate
parking and whether that would in
highways comments which are outlined in
the report relate to whether that then
an impact upon the public highway and so
that's where their objection lies so
it's a bouncer yes if with support from
the parish council there could they were
also concerned about parking were they
and what they've written so do we assume
that the parking authority but or not no
I wasn't anything we can't assume that I
think I think general the other thing we
just won two points I think answered
Blaine wants to support but not here we
can't hear what they've got to say in
support and we've said that previous
meetings if we haven't got any speakers
we would go to the recommendation and
that's what I'm proposing we do sorry I
say you I'm open Tony he didn't register
in time to speak so unfortunately it's
part of the price I'm not allowed to let
you speak on this occasion so I'm afraid
that is that's what we're going to say
sorry about that
and I'm tend to agree with capsule brain
so I think we should all if everyone's
happy go to go through the road we need
a proposal so yeah and how we got a
second apart Khosla cargo in favor you
know Thank You committee resolves to
refuse application 17 / 0 3 2 8 9 /
therefore you are
we okay counselor Williams okay would
you step pause pause for for two minutes
if that's all right well there whilst
that's the William stretches his legs if
you make it five minutes then so we'll
be back to start at 25 past we've got
five minutes counselor Kendall
just watch it the cancer can do what I
told the what I told mrs. Crump I'll be
back about now on the clocks that we
just wondered well you wanted to stay on
Oh cancel account also in Johnny's heart
oh right then well but we'll move
swiftly on to item number eight on the
agenda which is 18 / 0 zone 726 fe well
from inton court Loxy line was born for
application for the extension to
residential curtilage another
agricultural to residential change of
use the erection of Agra aged to
supersede the basement gage approved
under application reference 17 / 0 0 7 3
boy well on the use of the agricultural
access for agricultural and residential
thank you Jeff and so again as denoted
by a plus dot here the site is located
to the south west of the village while I
was born and to the northeast of Loxley
I will just run through that for clarity
as listed as of highlights on page 64
the application consists of four primary
elements including the extension of the
residential curtilage of the previously
consented dwelling the construction of a
single-story three-bay garage and
associated link extension alterations to
the access arrangements to the consented
dwelling including the utilization of an
existing agricultural access located
towards the northeastern corner of the
site and then associated harlem soft
landscaping works as per the development
and so this just outlines the site again
no no specific site constraints on this
one there is a public footpath that lies
to the e to the east for quite a
considerable distance from the site so
again from the narrow photography I've
just highlighted it with a star this is
actually the existing dwelling and farms
Court and this is a bit dated because
this is the historic building that I've
mentioned has had previous consent to be
changed for dwelling and then demolished
and then built as a dwelling again so
there's quite some history to this one
but generally speaking this is the
location plan and the curtilage
extension is largely here to the north
and then this is currently just the
concrete slab of where the building has
been demolished and this shows it in a
block plan form so this is what you
would see if you were to go onto site
today and you would see the existing
Farmington Court dwelling the concrete
slab and then this is currently open at
the none to the north obviously there
are some works here from the demolition
so this shows the proposal so this is
the the dwelling which does have
permission and then the the new elements
include this link extension here which
connects to a three-bay garage this is
the new access point proposed that will
connect to the existing agriculture
there's an agricultural entrance so we
utilize the agricultural entrance but
also provide a new domestic entrance
rather than the previous permission went
through here and the reason for the
garage as outlined is because there was
proposed to have basement parking on the
original planning application however
upon constructing the look into
constructed property and it's been noted
by the applicant that there's a high
water table and so basement parking has
it hasn't become a possibility so that's
why this is come forward these are just
some basic elevations just look in here
of each of each view to the property
from the east and west there and then
from the north and south and do we have
here some 3d visual visuals of how it
would look with the highway just running
here and this would sit in front of the
consented one so just some photos I've
got a number of photos here we can cycle
through and so this is looking towards
the curtilage extension to the north
from the existing access arrangements to
farmington in court
and this is looking back as I mentioned
the concrete slab where the works and
where the demolition of the existing
buildings have have already taken place
this is moving back in towards the
extended curtilage but yeah
suppose that shows the high water table
but this is roughly the area in which
the truck will take and this is the
existing agricultural access and then
you access the next field just through
here so this this access point does
exist but should be upgraded to is
proposed to be upgraded as part of the
application and then just the general
view now of the street scene where this
hedgerow boundary and this is the the
existing thumbs and court arrangement so
this is the access that is used to serve
the dwelling and at the moment is the
access with permission to serve the
proposed dwelling here and this is just
against the field just where the weather
Catholic extension is chaired the
recommendation is to refuse as per the
reasons outlined within the committee
report there are no updates on this one
either
thank you thank you it was good shared
the snow as well so very very
informative move on to our first speaker
which is Natasha de Silva
yeah and this is the applicant mr.
Butler he's just here to ask questions
rather than speaking if you have
anything you want to direct at him but I
would be taking three minutes
yeah I've not got a problem with that
but could you just let us know next time
right the first application so it would
be good if future reference thank you so
on this occasion I'm one happy predictor
applicant to be here as well so that's
one if I could have a 30-second warning
much appreciated thank you okay good
evening I am here speaking in support of
the application at Fallon Teen Court the
scheme has received support from the
Parish Council and there have been no
objections from any of the statutory
consort ease the post carriage will
comprise of free bays and a link to the
approved dwelling with materials that
are reminiscent of an agricultural
building the link is partially enclosed
with intermittent cladding and is wide
enough for a wheelchair to pass through
the drive will be grass creat and
indistinguishable from the surrounding
grassland part of the site was approved
for residential use under the 27 scheme
mentioned earlier for a purpose-built
dwelling
the garage is sited within the original
residential curtilage in the same
position as the previously approved
driveway and car lift limiting
encroachment into the open countryside
it'll be well screened by the
established eight-foot hedgerow the 2017
scheme included underground parking
which is no longer considered viable
although the site is in flood zone 1 the
clay soil is prone to poor surface water
drainage resulting resulting in a high
water table which would cause numerous
issues if a basement if basement car
parking was brought forward this would
cost in the region of 250,000 which is
not practical if it is unusable due to
flooding this scheme will use minimums
or an excavation as only the garage
Foundation's need to be dug recent SPD
states that garages should be sited to
the north of the dwelling as in this
case and can be in front of it in
exceptional circumstances the applicant
is disabled and uses two wheelchairs
daily one for work and one for home use
which he stores in his garage
access he can't leave a 3,000 pound
wheelchair in an unsecured space while
he's at work this guard suits his need
better than a subterranean one reliant
on lift access if it filled with water
his access would be restricted to the
dwelling there is no other practical
location for the garage which allows for
direct wheelchair access into the
property sharing an access with thumbkin
Court is also not an ideal situation as
it is on the market and will soon be in
separate ownership this scheme will give
both properties and individual access
and utilizes the existing agricultural
access to the applicants paddock as you
can see by the plan in corner
this is considered preferable to
creating another access between the
existing two access points it should be
noted that highways did not object to
this proposal the applicant is happy for
conditions to be imposed that the garage
supersedes the underground parking and
PD rights are removed as part of the
application we are happy to answer any
questions you may have that are
outstanding thank you the parking is to
the yeah to the red bit to the left the
red bit where the current entrance is
now yeah but there is so that where it
is all right there there's all park in
there so it's in the corner of that red
bit where the arrow was just a second
ago where the cursor was just a second
ago
yeah just sorry just to add to that
point the approve dwelling included a
car lift which is of basically where Bay
1 and Link is on the proposed one so
there's a parking turning area and a car
lift that which would have previously
gone down into the basement and we put
it on the same location mr. kogo thank
you I'm just Ted querying the
significant increase in the curtilage of
the site obviously the first
application have a very tight cookie
because it if I'm wrong as a touch cute
conversion and I think it originally did
get cost Q's consent originally did get
class q consent and then their full
application was putting to knock down
and rebuild but normally for a
prosecutor version of whatever it is
normal that the curtilage is extremely
tight normally but we've basically
doubled tripled it in this particular
application can you explain why thank
you for noticing and because of the
existing access that we needed
additional res central curtilage area
for the driveway to the access point
that we proposed to use it was decided
that instead of trying to keep it tight
to the driveway which would look at the
odd because it'd be quite close to the
main thing that this would look more
paddock like I would just have a better
boundary to it than trying to follow the
driveway exactly one question is can you
just confirm again why you're having
access through the field rather than the
existing one I know you touched I didn't
quite hear what sorry Farmington courts
currently on the market and will no
longer be in the ownership of the
applicant so the idea of sharing a drive
driveway between the two we thought
wouldn't be the best one whereas the
agricultural access is in the applicants
ownership and will remain in their
ownership so it's decided to share that
access instead thank you very much
there's no further PopCap's the brain
you sneaked in that last minute there
did you offer any special circumstances
to support your application could you
clarify about disability etc that was
included in the statement yes that we
are asking for this because of the fact
that he is in a wheelchair
and it would ease access into the
dwelling okay
perhaps even can be a wall and get some
more clarification from the office area
so I think that's a good point
good why is that all right thanks very
much Thank You Vince extinct will you
out sister thank you now we will move on
to the ward member who I accidentally
forgot earlier so sorry about that case
the Kendall about how can we forget you
it's okay thank you very much right I'll
try not to check the whole five minutes
if that's okay I've got two points after
us to start making really the first of
course is that the application is here
because of the support from the parish
council counselor brain made a very good
point earlier about us not liking it if
the parish council don't turn up this is
an oversight I a member of the parish
council so I'm here to represent and
speak on behalf of the parish as well as
ward member it seems little point to me
say taking two goes to say the same
thing so what I can say confusion at
parish council this was voted for I
think unanimously when it was discussed
a while back and the second point is I
think this application this site has
come back a number of times and not that
I'm I'm happy with the report it makes
some fair points I do feel that we're
starting to make a bit of a meal of it
we've demonstrated over and over again
and the main point of for this being
refused is to do with the that's being
allocated a rural location and being out
of keeping with the with the with the
scenery negative impact the thing we've
tried to establish over and over again
and this has been board members and
parish council is that we're very happy
with this the parish council are content
this is not detrimental to the
countryside the award member for me I'm
very happy this is not detrimental to
the countryside and this committee now
on two occasions before this at least
has also established they're happy that
this is not detrimental to the impact
have a detrimental impact to the country
so really I think although this and I
tech caps a car girls point that it is a
large extension with the removal
permitted development rights there's
very little you can do with the
extension of the curtilage really except
drive through it it won't damage the the
aspect and the countryside location at
all where content at the parish councils
I'm contentious the ward member that
this being permitted that is all I have
to say Thank You castle cannon so we'll
move on to the points of clarification
I'll notice the brains got one for the
officer regarding the special needs in
the application yes and so the
application it's always been aware that
this is for the purpose of wheelchair
access as well obviously if you read the
report it's obviously this is more
focused upon the impact as counsel
Kendall is highlighted upon the
landscape character and the the idea of
further encroachment effectively but I
was very aware of the of the situation
regarding the need for the storage of
this disability and access is all but
transfer cargo thank you okay let's just
get to the element we're talking about
here the expansion of the curtilage
which is significant in your opinion
could the access for the new garage
block be much much closer therefore
keeping the curtilage tighter I'm not a
highway expert and I appreciate what the
UM applicant and agent have said about
the not not wanting to share an access
and I also hear their opinion of
utilizing an existing access presumably
so you don't create another one in the
hedgerow whether an access could be
suitable in that location in and closer
to reduce the curtilage
without speaking for high-waist it
appears that visibility is it's a
straight road at the end of the day so
that could be a possibility
yep shortly
regardless of what the highways are said
if the damage was round the other way
would now start again if the underground
car park was still in the place doable
I assume the access would be by the
original access I can't speak for
whether the applicant would have come
back in to change the access a later
date but if they'd have built it out in
accordance with the original permission
then the access would have been here
would originally but obviously you've
heard tonight say James or Karen and
klasky was mentioned and obviously
concerned about again the precedent and
and also whether it's cross Q well it's
the fall and what are the implications
if we agree to this yeah this is quite
unique in that regard it was granted and
plus q well back in those days it was a
class NB so prior approval was granted
in 2014 in 2016 they received full
permission to demolish the barn because
the classic you wouldn't allow that they
came in to demolish the barn and an
erect a new dwelling that it's it's
forward of the building line of the
original dwelling obviously this is this
was the building on the darling and
appreciate the the the access lift was
would have sat in this sort of region
however wouldn't have the massing it's
not forward of the building line of
Farmington court but forwarded the
building line if they have proved like
thank you
right Casa Conda I just what also would
like to discuss your reasons for refusal
obviously the openness that can decide
which counts the Kendall has said that
the parish are happy with but the I said
it over domestication of a countryside
location would that have been the case
anyway because what we're saying here is
that or is it just simply the additional
access from the garage into the dwelling
this is that what you're saying the link
and my recommendation has been based
upon the idea just the additional
elements I as I've mentioned the the
garage is taller than what would what
the car laughs would have been it's just
the additional is what I thought this
and over domesticating further pushing
in from countryside the access track
because you can just see if I've showed
that winding track here tensely then the
best picture for that is looking back
into the field you get the garage side
of roughly in this location roughly with
the link coming off the off off so this
would be roughly about the approved
building will go the link come off and
the garage would sit in front it's a bit
hard to show that but could you
different through the other person all
of the photographs
pictures and drawings of the actual
proposed I'll go from the very back just
so you can see them in quick form so
this is just looking out outwardly so
this isn't isn't necessarily into the
site this is the existing access
arrangements from the highway the
existing agricultural access view into
the site where the curtilage extension
is where the garage will sit
beyond - just beyond this vehicle here
is the concrete slab that you can now
see fountain caught in behind and then
look in the other way and then so this
this is the roadside effectively looking
into the looking up the approved on
thank you thank you the bonds I just
check where this garage is going that is
you know inappropriate place and on the
pictures live so if I go back to
probably the best picture is this one so
if you you think this is the access
curving around so for just skip to you
that's at the curb in Rome oh so the
garage sits as I said approximately in
this list locations is difficult for me
to physically draw that one right I
think you've got the grilling where
James any other questions screen moves
to the debate catch the brain thank you
often to start again German I have a
certain amount of sympathy with this
application what my problem is is the
extension out into the open countryside
if the damage is round the other way
can use the existing drive then I'd be
happy with it
but I'll see what my colleagues say but
what a debate the extension into the
open countryside caster cargo thank you
well I echo that I do have to consider
about that I mean I get the I get the
flooding issue and I fully understand
that and you'd never know these things
until you actually start digging holes
and and so I saw understand the reason
for that and bringing the the change for
the impact is I
I take on board that there's an impact
with the with the garage being in front
and the linkage to it I don't buy the
fact you have to have a separate drive
because shared drives are not uncommon
in these circumstances so again I'm
uncomfortable about that but as I've
alluded to the whole evening is the size
of the increase in the curtilage from
what was a simple classic you conversion
will M be aware if it was that James
mentioned I mean it just seemed
disproportionate so that's why I am at
the moment Chancellor Barnes yes I was
surprised that there wasn't any personal
details in this application Oh in the
paperwork we had because it obviously is
a need without the garage there being a
pity will prove it but on in between
merely
a hype support I know it's an open
countryside but with other buildings
there and whatever I don't think it will
be too intrusive William C okay well yes
the facts of the facts we've got to face
up through this counselor brain says if
the carriage is real or hated he'd be
relaxed my thought is if we won't
support this he goes to appeal what
inspectors say would you just allow it
feeling he wouldn't so I just feel we
here well for parish councils support
because they say there's no other
alternative yet why can't they character
be reorientation that's my worry thank
you I just don't just say we're on this
one definitely special needs I think
that needs to be highlighted and they're
getting a lot of sympathy for not you
can see the Chinese upon his photograph
that the flooding was quite prevalent
and there certainly certainly merit on
this application our quota a member of
this committee who's who said in the
past and I'll leave you to imagine it
was if it's not quite right is wrong and
in the past we've also given
applications Weaver said he over got a
lot of sympathy for this but it's not
quite right and it needs to come back in
a better form or a different form taken
into account what we've said at this
committee and working with the offices
to where we can come forward with a
solution that's mutually acceptable so
on that basis I'm quite unhappy to to
support the application because I don't
think it's quite right I think it's got
a lot of merits and but I think it can
be improved so from my point of view on
I'm willing to go a long way of officers
recommendation and I'm looking for a
proposal on this okay service minded to
say to the applicant come back with an
amended application let us look at it
again the second echo exactly what
counsel Brian said because I just feel
that this is just not quite right but
I'd like to see it come back again and
then yes I'm sure we could support it
cancel bonds
I think the applicant and they and the
gentleman have heard what we've got to
say I think it's although we have to
review I think they can come back with
something that won't need to come to
committee but we'll you know suit they
need Chancellor Williams mr. chairman
I'm quite happy with the proposal or
just want me what assurances we got from
the planners themselves they all support
our thinking in this issue honestly I
think the planning manager is obviously
that's very close to me and and heard
your dulcet tones on several occasions
so
but I think that I think your point is
well made and I think I'm sure the
offices will take that on board and I'm
sure but it's just if it if we are
minded to refuse this application and if
it does come back I'm sure those points
will be taken on board so I will further
propose that in a second they're so good
about them please all those in favor for
German you guys non-german abstain
abstention one Chen all right so on this
item 18 / 0 0 76 76 ofyou know committee
resolves to refuse his application and
we have no other business so down to
business and number 10 start time of
meetings I think we need to decide
can you put your microphone on please
people I wondered if we could start at 6
o'clock instead of quarter past like the
other whether it's it's on but I just
have appropriate to saying yeah we're
all sitting here for a quarter of an
hour or so
I think it's perhaps I would be happy to
go to six but I know that the people
that counts the parrot I've got a
distance to come I'm sure she would say
in who she can't get here for 6 o'clock
because she has to come from work in
kind and I think it might be an idea if
we put this fort next meeting to discuss
and decide because it's only fair that
she get to be I'm happy to say to agree
with that I think that's fair so again
if obviously we've got two substitutes
here tonight and thank you very much
gentlemen for turning up but I think I
think that's a fair point and if we
could I just say it that's fine but what
would time would you want to start the
next meeting because if you're deciding
at the next meeting do we want to leave
the next one at 6:15 and put the item
back on the agenda I'm sure right that's
the end of the meeting thank you very
much